you should just be yourself not because
it will make you more likable it won't
but because it's only by being yourself
that you'll find people who like you for
who you really are rather than someone
you're pretending to be that's from
ginda Bogle and this was one of the
biggest realizations of my 20s the the
advantage of doing this thing where you
sort of push off who you really are is
that no criticism will ever fully land
because you're one degree removed from
the person who's being criticized the
disadvantage is that you're also removed
from the person who's being complimented
and if you're only playing a role you
never fully feel connected to the
successes that you have in your life any
accolades or warmth that you receive
won't resonate properly in your heart
because it's not you who's receiving it
it's the character that you're
pretending to be